hello everyone and welcome to yet
another video from round six of the 2019
Grantchester being played in Zagreb
Croatia it's Maxine Varsha holograph the
white pieces against Fabiano Caruana
and it's well it's really an exciting
game which you can see from the from the
photos here a lot of people checking out
their game there is see there's Magnus
checking out their game just you know
with with what a glass of juice behind
him and also here's a nice photo of
Levin checking out their games so
obviously there is something going on
there so let's let's just check it out
and as you all know it's a rest day
after around 6:00 so we will not be
having round 7 today but we will have it
yesterday of course after after it ends
so Maxime opens with E for sorry about
that with E 5 by Caruana Knight to f3
Knight to c6 with Bishop to b5 and now a
6 more fees defense
Bishop to a4 with 92 f6 and now
castles by white with Bishop to c5 and
now c3 with b5 by black pushing the
bishop back Bishop to b3 and now d6 and
this is something Maxime usually plays
with the white pieces and he in fact he
had this position for example against
almond in the other books no way
championship where he continued well
their game ended didn't draw the
classical one where Maxime continued
with d4 but then of course after the
classic one they went into the
Armageddon and then then they played the
exact same game and but in this point
Maxime went a 4 instead of d4 and this
is the move he chose to play against
Fabiano in this position so karana
continues Bishop to b7 with d3 by white
and now h6 so the same move basically
Anand played against Maxime in Norway
only the differences here Maxine Maxine
continued rook to e1 against talent but
here he goes a capture Sun b5 and ok a
captures with rook a personai 8 Queen
captures an a8 and now Knight state for
there is one game in the database that
reached this exact same position the
knight now wants to come to a5 and of
course you have to prevent it
in the one game that exists in the
database nice the e7 was played to
prevent night of fire but here Fabi goes
Bishop to see it and it is now a new
move preventing the knife from coming to
a5 and well we have a completely new
game so Knights the a3 putting pressure
on the b5 pawn here hoping to capture it
and Fabi goes to Bishop to g4 attacks
the Queen here now you could move the
Queen or you could maybe play Knight
back to f3 but if you go a knight back
to f3 then you get Bishop captures an a3
and after this captures you get Knight
a5 and then the Queen might be over you
know overloaded a bit here keeping an
eye on both sides of the board
so just Queen to c2 Maxine gets the
Queen out of the way and now Queen to b8
defending the pawn here and maybe even
preparing before with King to h1 you
want to prevent this pin pin from
bothering you also maybe you want to
play f4 at some point so King to h1 and
now you don't want to allow whites to
start pushing you want to start pushing
before that so g5 pushing the knight
back if you move the knight to f3 you
will mess up your pawn structure in
front of your King so of course nice 2fi
was played but an interesting line was
h3 which pushes the bishop back so it
allows you to go Knight to f3 without
messing up a pawn structure but then
Queen to c8 and black has a lot of
attacking potential here like capturing
an h3 you can push g4 you can prepare it
maybe go Ruby g8 h5 g 4 and a lot of
white pieces are stuck on the Queen side
and not really doing all that much so
here instead with nice - f5 he didn't go
for the for the h3 line so Bishop
captures an f5 you don't want to allow
this Knight to remain there it captures
and only now castles on King side as it
is very unlikely that white will be
doing any breakthroughs here on the King
side although
h4 is an interesting one since the
bishop already attacks g5 but after h4
black is just gonna go King g7 and now
if you trade here it's actually black
who will use the H file for the attack
for example Bishop captures you're just
gonna go rotate a check King you want
and now with this bishop controlling
this beautiful diagonal with the rook
here so it's a very nice attacking
position for black you're gonna go Queen
g8 Queen Age
and threaten some nice mates here so not
interested in breaking through wood age
for with Queen back to d1 and now comes
Knight to a5 putting pressure on the
shop here and here
maybe maybe King to g7 was a nice
preparation for a nice day five but far
besides to do without that so here with
Bishop captures on f7 check by Maxime as
the world by playing Knight to a5 of
Fabia allowed this b4 thrust so rook
captures on f7 b4 now preparing to win
back the piece Bishop captures C
captures and Knight back to c6 attacking
the b4 pawn Maxime defends it with
Knights to see - and now Queen to c8
going after the f5 point there's no more
going on not much is going on on the
Queen side anymore so far we know
transfers to game over to the King side
with g4 defending the f5 pawn you could
try Queen f3 defending it which attacks
the night but still you have to decide
where you want to play Queen to f3 or do
you wanna just a block the King side
ones with the g4 Maxime decides to go
for g4 and this well although it's now
prevents the Queen from capturing on f5
you will not be able to push on the King
side it does open up this very nice
diagonal fob you can use for attack so
he does we have Queen - a 8 now
threatening some nasty discoveries and
now f3 blocking this diagonal off but
now Quinta a 2 as now well the path to
the tiller King has been opened now you
might have some ideas of playing like
some like h5 capture here bring your
knife to g4 have some threats against
the h2 pawn a lot of things become
possible and it's very interesting how
Fabi how far be the first queen c8 force
the weakening with the g4 opening up
this diagonal then Queen to a8 forcing
another weakening that is that three and
then Quinta a two just very nice use of
the Queen we have d4 by Maxime and now
rook to e7
now we have D captures on e5 d captures
on e5 and now Queen to d3 waiting to see
what what black will do but black does
not wait as black already has a plan
with E for where you don't want to
capture if you capture
Knight to e5 first attacking the Queen
and after the Queen moves let's say
Queen d2 now we're gonna capture Nike
capture Sun g4 and there are so many
threats here you constantly have to be
aware of this threat as the knight now
covers the h2 square capturing here is a
threat and well it's just a much better
position for black so after E 4 with
Queen to c3
well attacking the knight here but for
the moment there's and there's no real
threat of of capturing it as Fabi goes
nicely 5 gets both of the knights out of
the way now this Knight blocks the
attack from this night and also it's now
a very dangerous piece here so what do
you do maxine pushes f4 attacks the
night and also threatens to break
through here on the kingside so again
what do you play here if you go Knight
to f3 with some ideas that if Queen
captures here you can capture here and
threaten some mates on h2 it doesn't
work because here Maxime has Bishop to
b2 and here you will be in a lot of
trouble you can't move the knight how do
you defend it you're gonna have to play
Queen to c4 force the Queen trade as now
the rook on f1 is under attack but it
all favors white because still you just
win the knight on f6 black does have a
compensation in terms of passed pawns
but it shouldn't be enough to fully
compensate so after f4 with Knight to d5
by Caruana
now again attacking the Queen and here
you have to play Queen d4 24 is the only
good move here for Maxime and then after
G characters on f4 Bishop captures on f4
you will get to Knight captures and g4
but now if the Knight captures you will
play rook g1 and now the night is on the
same file as as the king so you have to
defend it h3 now attacking the the
pinned piece and now after Knight
captures an f4 you will play H capture
Sun g4 and go into this align in the
Queen d5 over a queen trade first a nice
discover to check from the rope King h7
and now after you trade Queens you get
this position that is well it should be
should be better for black but it's it's
it was a muck seems the best best way of
playing the position instead after
Knight to d5
go queen d4 who went Quinta h3 but now
he'll out Fabi do too much in this
position it would seem III is the best
move here Fabi did not go for it but
it's it's a really nice line for example
if III and now you capture the night
then you get e to and now you see that
it's very complicated to play anywhere
with the rule for example if rook e1 you
capture the knight first and now you
have to well defend this pawn here for
example if you allow rook captures and
e5 then you also allow Queen captures
here and then after o captures you get
another queen into the game so let's say
Queen g3 defend the pawn and now Queenie
for check King g1 and now you can play
rook captures on e5 and now black will
just fall a wife will just fall apart so
III was a very nice idea here for fabu
but he finds a different line Knight to
f3 and now what do you play here here we
have night to e1
maxime doesn't want to allow Queen
captures in c2 so he moves the knight
although an interesting an interesting
idea was this pawn captures on g5 and if
Queen captures then you capture on age
six and three connected passed pawns in
front of the black king could be it
could be enough compensation for the
piece but it's again hard hard to decide
for for such a move when even black has
so many pieces in front of the White
King so a maxi moves it with night step
II won and here Fabi captures it also
possible was a queen to e2
sorry about that
also possible was Queen to e2 here and
then if Knight captures on f3 then you
get it captures on f3 and you already
get a very nice pass pawn here on f3
which you cannot capture because here
you just trade and after rook e1 you win
the bishop here so Bobby decided to
capture on any one with Knight captures
anyone and here you are Maxime you are
under attack pause the video here and
try it what do you play here what's the
best move for Maxime in this position
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it you
are an excellent pusher of pawns on f6
and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show not
capturing immediately but first f6 is
best because now you threaten a lot of
things for example if black moves the
rook to to a silly square then you can
even consider something like f7 you can
well first you will have to eliminate
denied because you can't constantly have
this well nasty threat of Queen g2 mate
lurking but for example even if Knight
captures on f6 now you play F captures
and g5 and you're still attacking to
pieces so it's not a problem H captors
and g5 and now you play rook captures
anyone and now you're you're still in
the game here what black is better of
course due to the test and defend it
efore passed pawn but you can capture on
g5 and you can you can also continue
playing the game here maxime recaptured
immediately he played rook captures
anyone and now Fabi just went III and
now it will be it will be hard so what
do you play here basically the choice is
either you capture on g5 or you try
Queen captures on h6 Queen captures on
h6 looks very nice but it really doesn't
work but I will leave it up to you to
decide why it doesn't work as usual so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an ex excellent
attacker of rooks and for those of you
just want to enjoy the show
Queen f2 is white it doesn't work
because here you have to see that after
Queen captures and g5 check you're going
to block with the rook and even Queen d8
check you can hide on h7 and now you
cannot capture here tonight as the rook
is under attack and after rook you won
you're gonna go Knight captures on f4
and there's no not much you can do here
there are too many threats here for
example Queen f3 check will be followed
by a rogue g2 and Queen captures with
mate so you have to prevent that let's
say Queen e8 but now you get a nice to
h3 attack the rook if you move it then
just e 2 will be winning I know your
only option is bringing the Queen back
and now you can just trade down and it's
completely winning now the knight is
protected you have to attack the pawn
rook captures with check you capture
here in Irish recheck the knight escapes
and well you are up up a whole rook
so after e3 with F captors and g5 the
only other option for
maxime but H chapters and g5 and now
Queen to g2 just offering the Queen
trade but Fabi the clients he plays
Queen to c4 and now he prepares rook to
e4 while he will have threats against
the g4 point also against the be for
pawn will be very hard to defend with
Queen to f3 my Maxime and now rook to e4
going after the G for pawn Maxime blocks
this and now we have looked f4 not even
bothering with the b4 pawn the Queen now
has to move with Queen to g3 and here
well father we just played the rook to
f1 check and it was in this position
that Marcia Marcia holograph resigned
the game because after you capture let's
say rook captures Queen captures you
don't have a good option here you can
move the King and then you lose the
bishop here or you can block with the
Queen and then you of course all see the
the move that follows either well there
are more movies that can follow you can
in place something like Queen captures
on h3 but the strongest one is e2 and
then you don't have a you don't have a
good move here you could try something
like push up to d2 to guard the e1
square but then you get nice to a3 and
again you don't have a move here with
white blacks and just continue the game
however he likes Queen h2 you're gonna
go Queen to f4 check King to h1 you're
gonna go Queen to f3 check and now it's
all over you block and get made it or
you go King h2 and now it's nice to f1
check and you no longer have a move you
have to capture the night we have Queen
captures here and then you can play just
pawn captures here and grab well
whatever you want you can grab a queen
and then well whatever you play just get
made it on the next move but of course
after rook to f1 check much semen
decided not not to continue this game
and it was in this position that he
resigned unmoved 37 sir
that's one more game from round six I do
hope you enjoyed it a very nice game in
the rule opus so always always nice to
see that and the very active play would
with the black pieces especially since
there was Maxine who who deviated from
from any an online that were previously
played so once again if you haven't seen
the previous two games from
round six do check him out and if you
don't want to then here are just the
standing slide Sarah just a short
glimpse at the standings
we have crossing in first followed by
new pony she Wesley so then a phobia of
Corona Dingley 11 onion
maxime beaugeois graph which aren't
announcer a hurricane on experiment Dara
and he Cora Nakamura still in last place
with two points so yeah like I said
today was a rest day so no games from
around 7:00 but we are gonna enjoy them
tomorrow and the OL awaited clash Napo
vs. Magnus so I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing this short coverage i
checking up in your suggestions and so
on and so on I think oh I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
evening